six years  you made a mistake but you can still  have a life  i didn't kill anyone  [Music]  500 shares netscape and 20th chef  i got a job for you in l.a  [Music]  we're going to make a lot of money  i'm a friend of slavis i'm here to pick  up his money they're a problem here  so what were you doing at that pawn shop  six years ago i get sent on some pickup  that lands me in jail we have got to  move on i am begging you  to let this go looks like you're doing  all right  welcome home brother  what was him ricky set me up  you're going to lose her just trying to  make things right  michael this is the beginning for you  they threatened our daughter i can't  trust you to keep us safe  go  i did as i was told you gotta see an old  friend you're gonna have a whole army  after you  you really made a mess  [Music]  you